Are you ready, kids?
KIDS:
Aye, aye, Captain!
I can't hear you.
( louder ):
Aye, aye, Captain!
♪ Oh... ♪
♪ Who lives in a pineapple
under the sea? ♪
♪ SpongeBob SquarePants! ♪
♪ Absorbent and yellow
and porous is he ♪
♪ SpongeBob SquarePants! ♪
♪ If nautical nonsense be
something you wish... ♪
♪ SpongeBob SquarePants! ♪
♪ Then drop on the deck
and flop like a fish ♪
♪ SpongeBob SquarePants! ♪
♪ Ready? ♪
( Captain laughs heartily )
( plays airy tune )
NARRATOR:
Ah, the sea.
So fascinating, so wonderful.
Here, we see Bikini Bottom
teeming with life,
home of one of
my favorite creatures,
SpongeBob SquarePants.
Yes, of course he lives
in a pineapple, you silly.
( clock ticking )
( snoring )
( spring boinging )
( foghorn blowing )
( snoring continues )
Today's the big day, Gary.
( meows )
Look at me, I'm naked!
Got to be in top physical
condition for today, Gary.
( meows )
( exhales loudly )
( grunting )
( groaning )
( panting )
( strained yell )
( toys squeak )
SPONGEBOB:
I'm ready!
I'm ready.
I'm ready! I'm ready!
I'm ready!
I'm ready...
Go, SpongeBob.
Whoa!
( crashing )
There it is...
the finest eating establishment
ever established for eating.
The Krusty Krab...
home of the Krabby Patty...
( exhaust gurgles )
with a "help wanted" sign
in the window.
For years I've been dreaming of
this moment.
I'm going to go in there,
march straight to the manager,
look him straight in the eye,
lay it on the line...
and I can't do this.
Patrick!
Where do you think you're going?
I was just...
No, you're not.
You're going to the Krusty Krab
and get that job!
I can't, don't you see?
I'm not good enough.
Whose first words were
"May I take your order"?
Mine were.
Who made a spatula
out of toothpicks in wood shop?
I did.
Who's the...?
( teeth grinding )
Who's...
( dramatic music playing )
Who's a big yellow cube
with holes?
I am!
Who's ready?
I'm ready!
I'm ready, I'm ready!
I'm ready...
I'm ready, I'm ready...
I'm ready!
Oh, no.
SpongeBob.
I'm ready,
I'm ready...
I'm ready!
What could he
possibly want?
Go, SpongeBob.
Go self!
Aah!
Mr. Krabs!
Hurry, Mr. Krabs.
Before it's too late.
I got to tell you...
SPONGEBOB:
Permission to come
aboard, Captain?
( deep voice ):
I've been training my whole life
for the day I could
join the Krusty crew.
( normal voice ):
And now I'm ready.
Whoa!
( hollering and grunting )
So, uh, when do I start?
Well, lad, it looks like you
don't even have your sea legs.
Mr. Krabs, please.
I'll prove
I'm fry cook material.
Ask Squidward.
He'll vouch for me.
No.
Well, lad, we'll
give you a test,
and if you pass, you'll
be on the Krusty crew.
Go out and fetch me, uh...
a... hydrodynamic
spatula...
with um... port and
starboard attachments,
and uh, a turbo drive.
And don't come back
till you get one.
Aye, aye, Captain.
One hydrodynamic spatula
with port and starboard
attachments, turbo drive,
coming right up, sir.
Carry on.
We'll never see
that lubber again.
You're terrible.
A hydro what?!
( both laughing )
SUB DRIVER:
Hey! Hey! Please!
Passengers are to remain seated
and do not put
their hands out the window.
( sub doors whoosh )
( Mr.Krabs
and Squidward laughing)
( gasps )
That sounded like hatch doors.
( sniffing )
Do you smell it?
That smell.
A kind of smelly smell...
a smelly smell that smells...
smelly.
Anchovies.
What?
Anchovies!
ANCHOVIES:
Eat, eat, eat, eat, eat...
Eat, eat, eat, eat,
eat, eat, eat, eat, eat, eat,
eat, eat, eat...
eat, eat, eat, eat, eat, eat...
Please, please...
quiet.
Is this any way
to behave? Hmm?
Eat.
SQUIDWARD:
Can we show a
little decency
and form a neat, single-file
line in front of the register?
Eat, eat, eat, eat, eat, eat...
♪ Barg'n-Mart ♪
♪ Meeting all
your spatula needs ♪
ANCHOVIES:
Eat, eat, eat...
MR. KRABS:
All hands on deck!
Get your anchors out
of your pants!
( Mr. Krabs yells )
SQUIDWARD:
One single-file line
is all I ask!
Whoa!
Batten down the hatches,
Mr. Squidward.
We're taking on
water, Mr. Squidward!
I want my mommy,
Mr. Squidward!
♪ Do, do, do-do-do ♪
♪ Spat-u-la, spat-u-la ♪
♪ Port and
starboard attachments... ♪
SQUIDWARD:
Help!
Eat, eat, eat, eat...
MR. KRABS:
Man overboard!
ANCHOVIES:
Eat, eat, eat, eat...
Climb, Mr.
Squidward.
Climb!
ANCHOVIES:
Eat, eat, eat, eat...
Eat, eat, eat, eat,
eat, eat, eat, eat...
This is the end.
Good-bye, Mr. Squidward.
Oh, Mr. Krabs.
( both sobbing )
SPONGEBOB ( over megaphone ):
Permission
to come aboard, Captain?
( humming fanfare )
( electronic beeping )
Did someone order a spatula?
( stammering gibberish )
That's right.
One hydrodynamic spatula
with port
and starboard attachments,
and let's not forget
the turbo drive.
( spluttering )
Would you believe they only had
one in stock?
( motor roaring )
To the kitchen!
Who's hungry?!
ANCHOVIES:
Eat, eat, eat, eat, eat, eat...
♪ Things that bother you
never bother me ♪
♪ I feel happy as pie, ha-ha! ♪
♪ Living in the sunlight,
loving in the moonlight ♪
♪ Having a wonderful time ♪
♪ Haven't got a lot,
I don't need a lot ♪
♪ Coffee's only a dime ♪
♪ Living in the sunlight,
loving in the moonlight ♪
♪ Having a wonderful time ♪
♪ Just take it from me ♪
♪ I'm just as free
as any daughter ♪
♪ I do what I like,
just when I like ♪
♪ And how I love it ♪
♪ I'm right here to stay,
when I'm old and gray ♪
♪ I'll be right in my prime ♪
♪ Living in the sunlight,
loving in the moonlight ♪
♪ Having a wonderful time ♪
♪ Doo-doo-doo, doo-doo-doo-doo ♪
♪ Doo-doo-doo,
doo-doo-doo-doo ♪
♪ Doo-doo-doo-doo, doo-doo
doo-doo, doo-doo-doo ♪
♪ Doo-doo-doo... ♪
( inhales, blows )
That was the finest
fast foodsmanship
I've ever seen,
Mr. SquarePants.
Welcome aboard.
But, but, Mr. Krabs...
Three cheers for SpongeBob!
Hip, hip!
Hooray.
Uh, Mr. Krabs...
Hip, hip!
Hooray.
Mr. Krabs...
I'll be in my quarters
counting up the booty.
Good morning, Krusty crew.
What would you like
to order, Patrick?
One Krabby Patty, please.
( beep, motor humming )
What?
( Patrick yelling )
SQUIDWARD:
Mr. Krabs! Mr. Krabs!
Mr. Krabs, come see
your new employee!
♪ ...having a wonderful time! ♪
( crashing, glass breaking )